قال رئيس الصنيشي جنبنك خلال الاجتماع
دوري للجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي ان وضع
الامن القومي الصيني معقد وخطير وفق ما
نقلت عنه صحيفه الشعب اليوميه الرسميه
ياتي هذا عقب تصريح للمتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه الجمعه الماضيه بشان تقارير عن
خطط امريكيه لشن هجمات الكترونيه تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه للصين
قالت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه من العلاقات
العسكريه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
مهمه للغايه وان الاتصالات والتبادلات بين
الجيشين لم تنقطع وتعليقا على رفض الصين
الاقتراح الامريكيه بعقد اجتماعي بين
وزيريه الدفاع البلدين في سنغافوره قال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره تانكي في فان الحوار
لابد ان تكون له مبادئ وان الصعوبات
الحاليه التي تواجه تبادلات بين جيشي
البلدين مصدرها الجانب الامريكي الذي على
حد وصفه يتجاهل مخاوف الصين ويخلق العقبات
مما يقوض بشكل خطير الثقه المتبادله وطلب
الولايات المتحده باظهار صدقها وتصحيح
اخطائها وتهيئه الظروف والاجواء اللازمه
للتواصل والتبادل بين الجانبين
الينا من بجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء شيماء
يعني هلا كي ان تضعين في تفصيل وتفسير هذه
التصريحات المتعلقه بالامن القومي الصيني
نعم محمد من الواضح ان تصريحات الرئيس
الصيني خلال اجتماعه باعضاء اللجنه
المركزيه للحزب الشيوعيه الصينيه الحاكم
مساء امس تاتي في سياق تطورات عدم ربما
ابرز وهو التوترات في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه خلال الاسبوع الماضي تحديدا
وذلك بعد اتهام الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للجانب الصيني بانه يقف وراء
عمليات قرصنه تستهدف منشات امريكيه هادئه
الاتهامات بنيت على تقارير تقول الصين
بانها تقارير من قبل ما تسميها بالعيون
الخمس وهي استخبارات الدول الاتيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بريطانيا
واستراليا كندا ونيوزيلندا تقول الصين بان
العيون الخمس تحاول من خلال هذه
الافتراءات على حسب تعبيرها ان تضرب الصين
وايضا ان تشوه صوره الصين على الصعيد
الدولي ولها مارب وغايات جيو سياسيه في
المنطقه تريد تحقيقها من خلال هذه
التقارير لكن في ذات الوقت هنالك تصريحات
ايضا من وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه الاسبوع
الماضي في ذات السياق تتحدث ايضا عن مخاطر
تهدد الصين امن الصين وسياده اراضيها
تحدثت المتحدثه الخارجيه الصينيه يوم
الجمعه الماضيه عن ان هنالك تقارير تم
تقديمها للحكومه الصينيه من قبل وكاله
الامن السيبراني الصينيه تؤكد بان هنالك
مساء من الحكومه الامريكيه منذ العام
الماضي للقيام بعده هجمات الكترونيه
تستهدف من خلالها البنيه التحتيه الرئيسيه
والحيويه للصين وفي هذا السياق ايضا تاتي
تصريحات الرئيس الصيني يوم امس خاصه وانه
ايضا ركز على جزئيه تطوير منظومه الامن
القومي وسرعه الاستجابه هنا داخل الصين
وقال ايضا بان المخاطر تهدد ايضا امن
البيانات في الصين بالتاتي بالتالي تاتي
هذه التصريحات لتنصب في نفس السياق محمد
شكرا لك يا شيماء
مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من بيجين